well get ready because our next guest is
one of America's top psychic mediums and
his readings will definitely raise the
hairs on the back of your neck
his nubile but not too hairy this is
great that's a weird thing to say anyway
his new book when heaven calls comes out
in March and here it is look at all good
a flock and he has a new reality show on
e called meet the Frasier's take a look
growing up being psychic was not easy
for me I tried my hardest to push this
ability away but I went to go to see a
medium about a girl that I liked about
all the normal teenage questions and
instead I left hearing that I was a
medium hold on and listening and I
actually had to leave my full-time job
as an EMT because I realized I could use
this ability to help people just in a
different way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so wait here's my question cuz like
people watch reality TV and I'm like how
real is reality TV cuz there's cameras
there so that's not real frightening so
listen I uh
yes it's well the good and bad parts oh
I'm on season 1 so I didn't know any
better than to just act myself I didn't
know I didn't know you kept doing that
don't be weird
yeah I didn't know how much of it would
be on TV or whatever I mean they said ok
ignore the cameras just go about your
daily business so you know I went about
my daily business I was on the bidet I'm
getting into my you know my man's space
wait a minute now little did I know that
this was going to end up on TV oh my god
I actually want to be such good friends
with you like the fact that you did that
is I talk about my Spanx all the time so
openly it's so great to bum a man thanks
well now I know listen I didn't know if
this faint community for men
he was like was like like when she was
underground
[Laughter]
[Applause]
don't wait I do the question oh so
you're here you're here like are you
feeling anything now yeah it's crazy
experiment to the audience like all I
see in here is dead people like I feel
like I'm connecting like the movie $0.06
you're that bone is like I feel like I'm
connecting with like the funeral home
because all these souls that are here
you know trying to speak and trying to
connect at first well your mom's apart
him your mom sitting right next to you
can I get up what what your mother's
right here the way that it works for me
is that when I'm in a room or Ramanand
in an area all of your soul so try to
come through and speak and she was just
sitting next to you and saying that's my
daughter that's my daughter so know what
your mom's way of just acknowledging
that you're here and letting you know
that she is okay this was a woman who
had suffered before her passing here in
the physical world because what happens
is Kelly's that they'll put me back in
their body to show me what had going on
and they'll stand next to to show that
they here and she showed me she couldn't
breathe before she had passed yeah she
said on a ventilator I feel like I'm
what like I'm drowning but I'm gonna
walk she had a heart attack I was in the
emergency room she was 62 years old your
mom says to me that first of all she
wants to thank you for keeping a promise
to her she says you promise to her that
you weren't gonna leave her side because
she was afraid she says in Juneau that
my daughter stayed with me all night
long and you laid on the side of her and
you laid with her and your mom just
wants to say thank you so much for
allowing my soul to go the other side
yeah can I give you a hug
[Applause]
all those details is so creepy and
awesome I am so glad I don't see dead
people though so please dead people here
in the room I can't handle it okay just
you know so Matt's new book when heaven
calls comes out and March here it is
he's calling everybody on this and don't
miss Matt on Meet the Frasier's Mondays
on e coming up we'll meet a couple who
helped put the bill for soldiers trying
to get home during the holiday season
please stay with us I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this